[Musica]
oggi
mi interpello sempre di più su che
diavolo di videogiochi sviluppino nel
2018 però non facciamoci queste domande
ai una big boss come molti di voi
conosceranno esiste un gioco simile
chiamato hai una build gai che far
saltare le meningi bene questo gioco è
simile game di soldi play a principi
designline sel del champ plate rock che
cosa c'era scritto va bene allora e smog
totali average moda ardon modo il conto
di tutorial ok walking chiaro chi è
ovvio charter piccola capito jump using
ze puoi fare il double giampà
esattamente come in iowa nabi lega è
molto chiaro ciò che sono un cartello
stradale qualcuno l'ha notata sta cosa
posso porca eva toscani sopore nel
tutorial a con l'aics sparo ok a puoi
restare in un punto preciso
ma porca eva difficilissimo il tutorial
ragazzi voi non avete idea è che due
maroni non riesco a sparare di non
riesco a colpire è l'ora che è
impossibile se ve lo giuro
praga il tutorial il tutorial è
impossibile nora che è veramente
impossibile sto gioco ve lo giuro su dio
è impossibile infattibile non riesco a
finire tutorial è difficilissimo
porca vacca è stato difficilissimo va
bene davide bossi vediamo come è
perfetto ma non da lì ma come non da qui
porca vacca mi riporterà indietro
addirittura va bene dobbiamo salvare
partito se non mi riparte ok vai che
hanno salvato da salvare per forza ogni
volta a una morte é poca una volta
porca vacca non me lo aspettavo mai
presse f5 to visit york trophies non lo
guardo è sicuramente visti più del gioco
come minimo
porca vacca che casino alcuni parti
proprio dei check point non puoi
ripartire da una schermata va bene che
ancora peggio porca vacca quanto è
difficile sopra sopra
ok no non sono capaci sti giochi ragazzi
c'è dei problemi vai salta no cero c'ero
porca vacca quanto sono studiato bene
niente se va da se mi fermo muoio se
vado avanti voglio cosa faccio
disinstallo gioco dimmelo tu
ok sono stupido sono stupido come la
morte c'era il punto li maledizione cioè
devo fare cercate di avere un tempismo
irreali suo gioco ma perché non salti
sbatti la testa ok c'è poi 4 essa è
stato impossibile già solo fare questo
solo fare questo è stato difficilissimo
come dovrei fare lì scusano in aula
spiega me credo di aver capito cosa io
debba fare però è difficile da spiegare
ok ok ok era perfetto ok perfetto
perfetto ok ma a destra sa se sta roba
c'è un tizio trigger finger ma sa in
base a come mi muovo si muove lui bene
buono a sapersi proviamoci
madonna no andava oltre il triangolo non
nuovo visto maledizione state ci provo
madonna quanto difficile ma porca eva
morta incastrata nel divano
mica è stato difficilissimo
dammi un check point che non mi dà
neanche un cieco quello è il check point
queste scene come faccio ad arrivare gli
spiega che ci provo
senza pensarci o lo fa chi era proprio
fa chi è a come potrei pensarci mai di
arrivare lì c'era siete scemi
ok madonna ma è impossibile o mi conceda
prova a fare meditazione yoga prima di
entrare faccio yoga allora piano
medicazione ce la puoi fare
fai cisl vado
rai è veramente la cosa più abominevole
che abbia mai giocato in tutta la mia
vita già arrivare qua mi chiese un
fenomeno ma porca vacca non mi fa fare
il doppio salto
allora io non posso più fare il doppio
salto una volta arrivato li hai capito
devo fare su tutto con un salto è
impossibile allora trovo della
difficoltà 80 dai perché ho sbattuto la
testa contro quello prima porca vacca
ma perché non sa di più perché lui sa di
più ma porca eva ma poi quando faccio
giusto mi fai fa sbagliato dai ma time
assalto l'assalto ma qual è il problema
risata il tempismo devi schiacciare
subito dopo che lo prendi qualcosa io
schiaccio subito niente non salta non
salta devi avere una precisione che
madonna
guarda che va pagato bene basta basta
basta di via via su schifo via piano
voglio più vederlo in poi sa per chi sei
che cosa fai se esisti muori ne voglio
più sapere
orribile ragazzi è stato basta a farmi
le famiglie un cristiano che fa a
sfiderà fa vedere bello da mamma dove si
fa viva da come esiste arrivato qua in
36 secondi bene
c'era un salvataggio non c'era nel mio
salvataggio vi prendete per i fondelli
chissenefrega del salvataggio tanto
riuscito a fare lo stesso li mortacci
mia spera ragazzi mi sia piaciuto
concludo qua sono contento di aver fatto
comunque un ottimo risultato e con
risultato intendo che ho fatto più
ripidi pie che a 60 e passa milioni di
iscritti quindi un po mary merito anche
io spero ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto
come al solito di velocità come te mi
piace ancora i soci come di tenersi
discrete e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo vita da ragazzi
[Musica]